but why is it blue and white I honestly
I don't know I think you do know this is
in support of Israel they changed I mean
it was like that actually since a few
months ago because we ran out of the
regular ones no I don't think so this is
obviously in support of Israel I mean we
have had St I I know this is not your
fault cuz you're an employee but I think
this is disgusting for them to do this
and I know you in your heart you know in
your heart that this is clearly what
this rapper is for I mean I didn't know
that though um um I'm explaining it to
you it is this is what it's for this is
the color of their flag this is clearly
what they're doing and what they're
showing to people and I think it's
disgusting it's clear you
know just like this morning when I got
out of bed and I stubbed my toe and I
knew it was the Jews I knew it I knew it
why are you looking at me like that okay
not take Flamingo what's this jacket
you're putting on me what are you
talking about